j'ai posé la question que tout le monde
te pose le picte arrivé de nancy à paris
pourquoi tom pourquoi novembre
il ya trente six façons de répondre
alors je prendrai la plus simple tom
slee minutes yves dejean thomas et
novembre c'est parce que je suis né au
mois de novembre et charlélie c'est
vraiment ton frère ou s'étant ton frère
allait en fait eu un fils adoptif ou
vous êtes frères de sons vous êtes avant
comme on l'a écrit
on peut tout ce qu'on veut c'est quoi ça
c'est comme un frère
vingt dix ans il fait partie de ma
famille alors tu fais des tu fais des
films tu fais des disques du fait des
tableaux tu fais des one man show sur
scène tu crois que tu es un touche à
tout un artiste polyvalent
moi j'irai un artiste polyvalent mais je
me suis déjà vu taxé de tous château ou
de papillons
enfin importance le
c'est le pollen qu'on promène c'est pas
trop les fleurs qu'on butine à laurent
40 a découvert enfin - tous les cas a
été découvert dans les isles avec lio
écluses et ouais et puis maintenant tu
en train de faire un malheur dans la
salle de bains 6 6 6 2
à 9h20 alors tout seul le film quand
même alors tout seul et a pas besoin de
mains pas de livre a déjà fait un malin
parce que ça s'est vendu sur un truc
assez c'est compliqué ça s'est vendu en
cinquante mille exemplaires en 1985 non
c'est ça à temps oui c'est à peu près
alors l'histoire n'y a pas d'histoire
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui qui
s'enferme dans une salle de bain qui
s'est installé aux rares oui c'est
simplement l'histoire d'un type qui veut
qu'on le laisse tranquille et qui laisse
les autres tranquilles ce qui n'empêche
pas moi je dis souvent c'est l'histoire
d'un type qui se retirent mais qui
s'absentent pas ouais alors bon il se
met dans la position du spectateur et il
en sort pas alors c'est toujours un peu
déroutant de quand on est soi-même
spectateurs dans une salle de cinéma ne
sort de d'opérer un transfert sur
quelqu'un qui est dans la même situation
que cole cd tom novembre en rivant la
soirée globe pour la salle de bains
douches froides ou bain chaud à vous de
voir
[Musique]
un personnage
cette semaine dont la santé est ce que
vous pourriez vous m'indiquer les
chemins de la salle de bain vous fait
plus
[Musique]
[Rires]
on ne
[Musique]
alors je sais pas c'est un peu comme le
film comme le bouquin est parti pour
faire école parce qu'il ya un grand
papier dans
englobe sûr surtout simples numéros de
groupe qui est sorti cette semaine et à
un papier dans l'actuelle aussi où on
parle de la génération salle de bain
alors on a un peu génération de vente ou
en ce moment faut bien le savoir
enfin c'est vrai que par rapport aux
années 70 qui était un peu vivant au
maximum et puis aux années 80 qui était
gagnon
là il ya un espèce de retour sur soi
même et qui n'est pas obligatoirement ce
qu'on a pu appeler le cocooning parce
que c'est du cocooning intelligent c'est
à dire c'est pas retrouvons nous chez
nous pour regarder sacrée soirée c'est
retrouvons-nous chez nous pour nom pour
lire pour penser que le personnage est
pas un paresseux il faut pas prendre le
personnage sous prétexte qu'ils restent
à domicile on va le prendre pour autant
pour un 1 1 fatigue et un f je prouverai
un cocon c'est vrai sauf que culturel
quoi un peu bohème dont on peut remplir
on peut remplir les espaces intérieurs
autant qu'on peut dépenser de l'énergie
acier de brasser de l'air à l'extérieur
on sait que c'est un point de vue
tu connais le portrait chinois ouais
voilà comme céline est mort va te faire
un anti forfait chinois fait prêt
allons-y
[Musique]
c'était une injure
une rigolote sûrs et est de ne serait il
malade y est
une maladie ce pôle karting sonne ou un
truc comme ça arrive quand même
ouais un microbe
pour une grippe une grippe quelconque
reptiles reptiles un serpent à lunettes
pourquoi poser lunettes ça sympa les
serpents on our house blanche c'est
comme si tu étais une infirmité
c'est dur je serai pas aveugle va
peut-être muette
si tu étais un assassin du srecki comme
assassin or jacques l'éventreur on en
parle encore un vice à la vertu
une guerre
un petit conflit de rien du tout
dans entre deux tribus afrique un
supplice
on en a plus a inventé que deux
positions pour baiser comme celle
difficile le choix alors j'irai la roue
peut-être faits atroces pourquoi ces
lumières celle on vous laissera pas
peut-être
c'est quand on suspend le mec au dessus
d'une corde
j'ai pas dit m et puis on laisse tomber
la corde alors ils tombent au sol et en
remonte et on laisse tomber indéfiniment
pas ce que fait nicolas hulot tous les
samedis dans ushuaïa quoi
malheureusement un élastique ce qui peut
dire monde tout seul c'est pour ça un
accident
d'accord de castres un accident j'ai pas
un de la route
un quotidien et si tu étais une
cicatrice
elle serait ou sous l'aisselle gauche
probablement réuni droit parfois une
histoire comme ça le cicatrices n'y a
pas besoin de frimer avec les plus
belles sont intérieurs aux hautement
ouais ça fait un peu prétentieux de dire
ça mais
je crois que m'en donner plein mais on
les voit pas tout et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
y mettez un peu de bleu